with his approval rating still among
some of the lowest of his presidency Joe
Biden delivered his second State of the
Union Address and despite still soaring
high inflation Biden declared backbone
is nation is strong Millions tuned in to
watch Biden who used his speech to
highlight what he sees as his successes
of the past two years not employment
rate is a 3.4 percent of 50-year low
near record unemployment for Black and
Hispanic workers we've already created
your help eight hundred thousand good
pain manufacturing jobs the fastest
growth in 40 years but this state of the
union was different from Biden's last
this time the Democratic president spoke
to a divided Congress as he made the
case for raising America's debt ceiling
and protecting social programs from
spending cuts he was challenged by
Republican lawmakers
that means Congress doesn't vote
well I'm glad to see unfazed by the
criticism Biden sought to bridge
Washington's political divide turning to
his opponents and using the speech to
negotiate with them directly a stand-up
for seniors
but I didn't also honored Tire y Nichols
the 29 year old man beaten by Memphis
police officers as Nichol's mother and
stepfather looked on Biden urged
Congress to invest more in police
training something good must come from
this
codifying women's rights to an abortion
was another priority make no mistake
about it if Congress passes a national
ban I will veto it well Biden's speech
focused mainly on domestic policy he
once again underscored America's support
for Ukraine following the Downing of a
Chinese spy balloon after it crossed the
United States He issued this warning
as we made clear last week if China
threatens our sovereignty we will act to
protect our country and we did but
Republicans had their own rebuttal from
out of control inflation and violent
crime to the dangerous border crisis and
threat from China
Biden and the Democrats have failed you
President Biden used his address to
reflect on his accomplishments and lay
out his agenda for another term in
office it's been widely reported that
Biden's senior aides preparing for the
president to announce his re-election
bid sometime later this month Kimberly
Helk at Al Jazeera Capitol Hill